السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قالت وسائل
الاعلام السوريه ان بلده القصير سقطت
بالكامل بيد الجيش السوري ومقاتلي حزب
الله الذين يدعمونه بعد اكثر من ثلاث
اسابيع من القتال الشرس مع مقاتل المعارضه
السوريه المسلحه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين الى اي مدى ستحدد نتائج معركه قصير
مسار الثوره
السوريه وما هي التغييرات المحتمله في
مواقف الاطراف الدوليه المسانده لمعارض
نظام
الاسد قالت المعارك الميدانيه الشرسه
كلمتها سلمت القصير الى قابضه الجيش
النظامي السوري مدعوما بمقاتلي حزب الله
في منعرج فتح الباب واسعا للحديث في
تبعاته السياسيه التي تشمل جميع اطراف
الازمه السوريه والمعنيين بها اقليميا
ودوليا ترى هل ستتدخل الدول الغربيه ام ان
اسقف المعارضه سينخفض بالنظر الى تراجعها
الميداني وهل قربت معركه القصير بما
استقرت عليه موعد انعقاد جنيف اثنين اسئله
تستدعي في نظر كثيرين الحديث عن العمق
السياسي لما حدث في القصير عن من تحول
عسكري سيطر الجيش النظامي السوري على
مدينه القصير الاستراتيجيه بعد معارك
ضاريه مع مقاتل الجيش الحر احتدمت في
الاسبوعين الاخيرين بعد ان ظلت المعارضه
تسيطر على المدينه لاكثر من عام دون ان
يعترف النظام علنا
بذلك الموالون للنظام يرون في النصر الذي
تحقق نجاحا كبيرا لاسترا جيته العسكريه
التي لم تعجل في سبيل استنزاف وانهاء بؤر
وتجمعات الجيش الحر ومؤيديه في القصير
ومحيطها والمعارضه اعترفت بفقدان القصير
ويقول عناصرها انهم لم يواجهوا جيشا
مقتحما انما تعرضت المدينه لوابل من القصف
زاد عن 50 قذيفه في الدقيقه ومع تزايد
الضحايا اضطروا لشق الطريق لاخلاء الجرحى
ومغادره المدينه اهميه القصير تكمن في
موقعها على طريق امداد حيوي بين سوريا
ولبنان والقريب ايضا من حمص ثالث كبريات
المدن السوريه وبغض النظر عن من يسيطر
عليها فان تعقيدات موقعها تبقيها مفتوحه
تتفاعل مع مختلف التطورات
وتداعياتها وفي الذهن المعطيات الاخيره
التي تحدثت عن دعم حزب الله للنظام
واشتراك عناصر من الحزب في حرب القصير
وايضا ما يتحدث عنه النظام ويصفه بالبؤر
الارهابيه التي ترفض المعارضه عبر الحدود
مع لبنان من ناحيه ثانيه سيطر النظام
السوري على القصير في وقت دقيق للغايه
يتهيا فيه المجتمع الدولي لعقد مؤتمر
لسلام سوريا بجنيف صحيح ان فرص انعقاد
المؤتمر تبض ضئيله حتى الان على ضوء مواقف
الطرفين ولكن صحيح ايضا ان ايا منهما لن
يرغب في حضور المؤتمر حال انعقاده وهو في
موقف ضعف ويظل مستقبل الصراع السوري في
القصير وغيرها مفتوحا وهل سيطبق النظام
استراتيجيته التي تحدث عنها في القصير في
مواقع اخرى لدحر معارضيه وكيف سيكون شكل
التطورات وقد اعلنت المعارضه العوده
لاستراتيجيه حرب استنزاف
النظام وموضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع من
بيروت الكاتب والباحث السياسي محمد عبيد
وفي الاستديو رامي اللاتي عضو القياده
العسكريه العليا للجيش السوري الحر ومن
واشنطن الدكتور خالد جشان استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه بفردين مرحبا بضيوفنا
الكرام استاذ محمد عبيد ماذا يعني
بالنسبه للنظام السوري لحلفاء حزب الله
وايران ومن يسانده دوليا السيطره على
القصير لماذا كل هذا هذه الفرحه وهذه هذا
الانتشاء الذي شاهدناه
اليوم يعني هي ليست فرحه ولا انتشاء عمليا
انما ما يسمى بالمعارضه السوريه هي التي
جعلت من مدينه القصير ومن ريفها موقعا
استراتيجيا وهي التي روجت ع عبر وسائل
اعلامها ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بان هم او هذه المعارضه صامده في هذه
المدينه وانها مدينه استراتيجيه وان الجيش
لن يتمكن من السيطره او من استعادتها لذلك
المعارضه المسلحه هي التي جعلت من القصير
امرا استراتيجيا ولكن اذا عدنا بالذكر الى
الوراء نتذكر حينما حزب الله كان يعني
يقال بانه يقاتل الى جانب ننظام في القصير
رد بانه يدافع عن قرى شيعيه في المنطقه
اذا كنت
تتذكر يعني سنعود اذا الى النقاش حول
موضوع تدخل حزب الله انما لنعود الى موضوع
مدينه القصير بالواقع اهميه مدينه القصير
انها هي الممر الاساسي لما اسميته سابقا
الكوريدور المفتوح ما بين لبنان وسوريا
لتهريب المقاتلين والاسلحه الى تلك
المنطقه لاستنزاف الجيش العربي السوري من
جهه ومن جهه اخرى لتوريط لبنان اكثر في
تلك المنطقه هي بوابه لمحافظه حمص كامله
هذه المحافظه التي بمساحتها
وامتدادها اذا تمت سيطره المعارضه المسلحه
عليها ست تؤدي الى تقسيم سوريا الى جزئين
اي عزل دمشق عن الساحل السوري وعن مناطق
اخرى الى جانب الطريق الدوليه التي تربط
الساحل السوري بدمشق بحما وبا ادلب
والمناطق الاخرى لذلك اهميه هذه المدينه
ابتدعتها المعارضه انما هذا لا ينفي ان
هذه المدينه لها اهميه قصوى
وهذه المواجهه اعتقد انها ستمتد لتشمل او
محاولات سيطره الجيش السوري ستمتد لتشمل
كل القصير وريف حمص ومدينه حمص لانهاء هذه
الحاله الشاذه القائمه في تلك المنطقه
واستعاده الدوله السوريه لوضعها الطبيعي
وعوده الاهالي وبذلك تكون الدوله السوريه
قد حققت انجازا اساسيا اعتقد انه سيقنا من
التسويه السياسيه يعني الشيخ رامي اللاتي
انتم من جعلتم من قصير واوليت موها كل هذا
الاهتمام وانما بينما هي في نظر النظام
جبهه كباقي الجبهات وبالتالي انتم من
صنعتم القصير اسما اعلاميا يحضى كل بكل
هذا الاهتمام وجعلتم منها هذه المدينه
الاستراتيجيه التي ربما الحسم في معركتها
قد يغير الكثير من مسارات الثوره بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم بدايه اقدر للصديق في لبنان
هذه النبره الخجوله من انه فعلا ليس لم
يعتبر ان ما جرى في القصير هو نصر حقيقي
واي عربي لديه اي حد ادنى من الكرامه
والانسانيه يعتذر عما يجري في القصير الان
اخي الكريم معركه القصير يجب ان يعرف
العالم ماذا جرى حقيقه في القصير ما جرى
في القصير انا لا اوافق على مصطلح السقوط
القصير وانما ما جرى انه عندما فشل النظام
وقوات الغزات عن كسر اراده الثوار على
الارض تقصد حزب الله نعم الغزات من حزب
الله اي قرروا ان يعتمدوا سياسه الحرب
القذره او الذراع الطويله ما يسمى في
منطقه الح حروب فاتجهوا الى قصف الاماكن
المدنيه الامنه باطلاق بغزاره نين كبيره
عندها قررت قياده الجيش السوري الحر
الانسحاب تكتيكيه من المنطقه لتجنيب
المنطقه مزيد من قتل المدنيين عندما شعر
النظام بضعفه قرر ان يكسر اراده الجيش
السوري الحر بقتل المدنيين وبالتالي ما
جرى في منطقه القصير هو متفهم بالنسبه لنا
هذا السيناريو كرره النظام في باب عمر في
داريا في مع ذلك ان المعارك الاخيره لم
يسقط فيها عدد كبير من قتلى المعارضه
المسلحه وانما كان هناك انسحاب حسب ما
تقول نعم اخي النظام فوجئ انه في معركه
القصير ليس في نزه هو كان امام معركه
حقيقيه امام اراده قويه من الثور على
الارض وبالتالي الانسحاب هو انسحاب تكتيكي
مدروس بالدقه ولا اخفيك انه لم يقرر خلال
ساعه ضحاها هو مدروس منذ فتره انسحاب
النظام انسحاب قوات الثوار على الارض من
هذه المنطقه المغلقه لينتشروا على مساحات
جغرافيه كبرى وذلك بعد ان امنا خروج
المدنيين جميعا من تلك المنطقه المدنيون
متجمعون الى منطقه البويضه متجمعون الان
في منطقه البويضه وهذا نضع المجتمع الدولي
الان امام استحقاقاته اي مجزره اي عمليه
قتل ستجري في منطقه البويضه نحن اعلنا
انها منطقه مدنيه بحته وبالتالي المجتمع
الدولي امام استحقاقاته تجاه المدنيين في
تلك المنطقه دكتور خاليل جاشان استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه بيبر داين يعني
هذه المعركه
وما يعني انتهت اليه الان من استعاده
النظام وحلفائه السيط السيطره عليها كيف
كان اصداؤها في واشنطن والي حد ربما تنعكس
على هذا الجدل الدائر داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الاداره الامريكيه
بين من يتهم اداره اوباما بتقاعس وبين من
يدعو الى تسليح المعارضه المعتدله كما هو
تيار جون ماكين هل سيغلب ما جرى الان من
تطورات ميدانيه وجهه نظر طرف على وجهه نظر
الطرف
الاخر
بدون اي شك يعني اولا لا شك ان هذه
النتائج وسقوط القصير من جديد
بايدي قوات الجيش النظامي لا شك انه يشكل
يعني مصدر قلق للاداره الامريكيه بالنسبه
لابعاده
وتساقطه السياسيه على المدى البعيد ولكن
اجمالا اعتقد اننا سنلاحظ خلال ربما يوم
او يومين توجيه اصابع الاتهام من خصوصا
المعارضه التي اتهمت كما تفضلتم الاداره
بالتقاعس تحاول ان تلوم الاداره لهذه
النتائج وطبعا مدعيه بان لو قام الغرب
اجمالا وخصوصا الولايات المتحده بتسليح ال
المعارضه وتزويدها بما تحتاج له من اسلحه
وعتاد منذ فتره طويله لكانت النتائج تختلف
كليا عنما شاهدنا اي بالامس ف فاعتقد ان
الاداره ستواجه المزيد من الانتقادات خلال
الساعات
والايام المقبله نتيجه يعني
لهذه الاخبار التي وصلت واشنطن من سوريا
الى اي حد ربما تجد نفسها الاداره
الامريكيه محرجه اكثر حينما تصدر تصريحات
من فرنسا وبريطانيا من
حليفيه تفيد بان هناك ادله ملموسه على
استخدام غاز السارين من قبل النظام
السوري وهذا الامر كان خط احمر ل الادار
شخصيا اعتقد
ايه انا شخصيا اعتقد ذلك سيكون هناك
المزيد من الاحراج بالنسبه للاداره خصوصا
اذا ما تم بالفعل شن حمله
دعائيه قويه هنا داخل الولايات المتحده
حول تقصير الاداره في الامدادات
والمساعدات التي وعدت ولكن لم يتم تنفيذها
في الماضي بالنسبه
للمعارضه السوريه ولكن في نفس الوقت
بالنسبه للمخابرات الامريكيه لا اعتقد ان
هناك اي تفاجؤ بالنسبه لهذه النتائج خصوصا
في ظل التصريحات التي سمعناها من بعض
المصادر خلال الايام القليله الماضيه داخل
المخابرات الامريكيه وايضا من بعض
المخابرات اجهزه المخابرات الاوروبيه
خصوصا الالمانيه التي اصرت بان النظام قد
تحسن اداؤه في الواقع يعني وصل الى مفترق
طرق جديد في النزاع في سوريا وهو يعني في
في وضع امن اكثر من اي وقت اخر خلال
السنتين الماضيتين فمن ناحيه ليس هناك من
اي تفاجؤ ولكن من الناحيه الاخرى هناك
بدون اي شك سياسيا على الاقل بعض الاحراج
بالنسبه للاداره وسياسيا اريد اسال هنا
محمد عبيد في بيروت بعدما ربما كسب النظام
السوري وحلفائه بعض النقاط في هذه الحرب
لان الحرب لم تنتهي انما هي معركه الان في
القصير كيف سيستثمر هذا التطور الميداني
او هذا المكسب اذا جزنا ان نقول بالنسبه
له والعالم والمجتمع الدولي يستعد ويحضر
لمؤتمر دولي للسلام حول سوريا جنيف
اثنين يعني اولا ارجو ان لا يتم تاويل او
تفسير موقفي من قبل ضيفك ضيفك ال في
الاستوديو بانني لا اعتبر ما حصل نصرا هو
نصر بالتاكيد على قوى المعارضه بدءا من
جبهه النصره وصولا الى الجيش السوري الحر
وليس نصرا على الشعب السوري وهو نصر
للدوله السوريه انما هو ليس مدار تبجح
بصراحه انما اودت ان اؤكد ان الوقائع التي
س تتتالى في على الارض ميدانيا في محافظه
حمص وفي محافظات اخرى ستؤدي الى استعاده
الدوله السوريه لسيطرتها على كامل الاراضي
والموقع او الوضع الان ليس وحزب الله يعني
ليس في موقع الاحتفال من باب انه يحترم
تضحيات الشعب السوري ومن باب انه معني
بهالمرض معركه لجبهه بامريكيه اسرائيليه
تكفيريه اما لجهه اي مواجهه او كيفيه
استثمار هذه المعركه او هذه المتغيرات
الميدانيه التاكيد ان ما حصل في مدينه
القصير وما سيحصل من انجازات متلاحقه
قريبا اي ثبت او اوجد تفسيرا واقعيا لبيان
جنيف بمعنى انه تم تثبيت موقع رئاسه
الرئيس الدكتور بشار الاسد في الحوار وفي
التفاوض من خلال من يمثله في هذه العمليه
لان واضح ان اي ما يسمى بالمعارضه المسلحه
في وضع تقهقر وواضح ان الدول التي كانت
تدعم
هذه المعارضه هي الان ايضا في وضع محرج
لانها اعطت هذه المعارضه كل ما يمكن ان
تعطيه انما هذه المعارضه لم تجتمع لم هي
اسمها ائتلاف لكنها لم تتالف فعلا ولم
تتخذ موقفا موحدا الى جانب انها مجموعات
مسلحه متفرقه تحت عناوين مختلفه ولكل مش
هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه اعتقد
ان الان من المؤكد ان حزب الله
والقياده السوريه وحتى الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه ستكون في حذر لان هذه
المواجهه ايضا اظهرت قوه مميزه لمقاتلي
حزب الله على الارض اكتساب خبرات جديده
ايضا الى جانب ان حزب الله بعد هذا هذه
المواجهات اصبح اكثر انتشارا ونفوذا على
المستوى
المعنوي في العالمين العربي و الاسلامي
وعلى المستوى الدولي ولذلك راينا اكثر من
موقف حتى من الاداره الامريكيه حول هذا
الموضوع لذلك الحذر الان من المؤكد انهم
سيكونون في وضع حذر لان العدو الاسرائيلي
في لحظه ما ممكن ان يسعى الى تغيير
المعادلات على الارض وبالتالي ستكون هناك
مواجهه او
في المنطقه انما حسب معلوماتي او معطيات
فان قدرات الحزب حتى على
مستوى المواجهه او التحضيرات او
الامكانيات في جنوب لبنان ايضا كبيره
كبيره جدا وهي ليست يعني معنيه بما يجري
في سوريا هناك من يقاتل في سوريا وهناك
ايضا من هو جاهز للقتال في جنوب لبنان
يعني هذا هذا المكسب الميداني كما يبدو من
جوابك اكسب النظام وحلفائه ثقه
في النفس وثقه ايضا في المضي بعيدا في هذه
المعركه وبات لديه امال في تحقيق نتائج
ميدانيه وسياسيه وقريبا كما قال ضيفنا
سنحاول بعد الفاصل ان نقرا في نتائج معركه
القصير ايضا من سياسات الدول على سياسات
الدول الغربيه تجاه الازمه السوريه فنرجو
ان تبقوا معنا مشاهدينا
الكرام اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام من جديد
في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش اداعيه السياسيه
لنتائج معركه القصير مرحبا بضيوفنا الكرام
مره اخرى الشيخ رامي اللاتي سمعت ما قال
الاستاذ محمد عبيد من بيروت طبعا تكلم
بنبره المنتصر الواثق وايضا بنبره الذي
سيحقق قريبا
نتائج سيجني نتائج سياسيه وميدانيه من من
ما جرى في معركه القصير كيف ترد على هذا
الامر بدايه استاذ عبد الصمد اسمح لي ان
اسحب تقديري سابق لم موقفه الانساني الذي
ظننت للحظه من اللحظات انه موقف انساني
تجاه المساله السوريه هو يتوجه يتبجح
بالنصر في معركه القصير اقول يعني من
المحزن ان يتبجح صديق لبناني بيننا وبينه
اخوه العرب والاسلام والعروبه ان يتبجح
بالنصر على الاصدقائ السوريين ثم يلبسها
لبوس ال جبهه النصره والتكفرين وهذه
الميديا الاعلاميه الضخمه ثانيا ايضا من
المؤسف حقا ان يقول ان كتائب وميل حزب
الله قد اخذت خبره كبيره على الارض كان
الاولى ان تكون هذه الخبره في جنوب لبنان
تجاه اسرائيل الذي يدعي مقاومته ومانعي في
اسرائيل لا ان يتبجح ان حزب الله قد اخذ
خبره كبيره على دماء السوريين اخوانه
السوريين كما اشار هو سابقا ان مدينه
القصير باختصار كانت ممر للعصابات
الارهابيه اقول انها سابقا كانت هي الطريق
الممر لاسلحه حزب الله باتجاه من الحكومه
السوريه الى حزب الله عبر مدينه القصير
ونحن ندرك هذ المعلوم با تماما بامتياز
بالنسبه للمواقف السياسيه هم لا ينكرونها
لا ينكرون ذك نعم نقول الان هم حريصون على
مدينه القصير اكثر من حرصنا نحن كسوريين
على منطقه القصير نحن ندرك هذه المعركه هو
قال كلاما مهما قال ان هذا الامر سيقوي
موقف النظام السوري الذي زاده ثباتا وزاده
مصداقيه في التفاوض في في مؤتمر جنيف
وايضا زكى واعطى قوه لموقف حلفائه بينما
الذين دعموه وحققوا نتيجه بينما الذين
ادعوا انهم يد الثوره تقاعسوا وانتكس نعم
لعل هذه الرساله تصل الى اصدقاء
السوريين من الاوروبيين ومن الاشقاء العرب
الذين يدركون ان الان السوريين يخضون
بدمائهم حربا عن الامه لعلهم يدركون
ويتحرك ما بقي لديه من بقايا الضمير
الانساني في اعماقهم ويساعد السوريين كما
تساعد الايران وتشرع دخولها وكما شرعنا
حزب الله دخول دخوله الى سوريا للحفاظ على
الاضرحه وليس على الاحياء على الاض ضه في
سوريا اقول النظام ربما يستثمر هذا بطريقه
تنقذه في مؤتمر جنيف نحن نعتقد ان جنيف هي
اخر طوق نجاه سيلقى للنظام السوري نحن
كثوار لسنا معنيين بمؤتمر جنيف نحن نعتقد
اننا نملك امراك القوه الكبرى على الارض
لس معنين بمؤتمر جنيف لسنا معنيين بمؤتمر
جنيف على العكس تماما معركه القصير تورت
حزب الله هذه العربده العسكريه للقوات
اجنبيه على ارض سوريا الحبيبه زيدنا
اصرارا اننا نحن امام معركه عسكريه
بامتياز لن نضعف لن نستكين اعتقد انه
سيكون لدى المعارضه السياسيه مزيد من
الاصرار ان الحل في سوريا الان هو حل
عسكري بامتياز كما شرعنا حزب الله والغزاه
الذين جاءوا معه عكس هذا عكس ما كان قاله
جون كيري وزير الخارجيه الامريكي سابقا في
بدايات الازمه في الاشهر الاولى الازمه
حينما قال بان لا حاله تفاوضي او سياسي
الا الا اذا غير الاسد حساباته على الارض
دكتور خالد جشان هنا اريد ان اسالك يعني
هذا التصريح لكيري طبعا صرح به قبل اشهر
وكان موقف النظام في حرج اكثر الان النظام
بات ربما في في في موقع يؤهله لان يتحدث
بصوت اعلى وربما قد يكون مؤهلا ايضا ل
للثبات في موقفه وعدم تقديم تنازلات يعني
هل ما زال لدى امريكا الان بعد هذه
الانجازات الميدانيه الاخيره في القصير
بالنسبه للنظام اي امل بان يتنازل الاسد
او يغير من حساب او يقدم اي شيء
للمعارضه اولا بدون اي شك يعني التصريحات
التي سمعناها من كيري قبل بضعه اشهر هي
ليست نفس المواقف التي يتبناها كيري اليوم
يعني شهر ايار في
الواقع شاهد تغيير جذري في الموقف
الامريكي نتيجه التبادل وربما التوافق في
المواقف بين واشنطن وموسكو تجاه هذا
الموضوع طبعا الاداره الامريكيه ما زالت
متمسكه بان الحل في سوريا لا يكمن في حل
عسكري محض وان الحل السياسي هو الطريق
الافضل بالنسبه لمصلحه الشعب السوري ومن
هنا تمسك الولايات المتحده او دعمها لفكره
جنيف اثنين ولكن الان انا انا شخصيا يعني
اعتقد ان هذه التطورات الان على ارض
المعركه لم لم تغير فقط
ميزان القوى على ارض المعركه انما قد تقود
في الواقع الى الضحيه الاولى الضحيه
الاولى من الممكن ان ان ان تكون جنيف
اثنين نتيجه كيفيه تعامل النظام مع هذا
المكسب وكيفيه تعامل المعارضه او او
الثوره مع
هذا ا
دور سيناريوهات يعني كيف يمكن ان يكون
جنيف اثنين ضحيه جنيف اثنين ممكن يكن ضحيه
لانه الان تاجل تاجل لاسباب يعني غير
مباشره بالنسبه لما جرى في القصير تغير
لاسباب ان هناك خلافات في صفوف
المعارضه والمشاركين ولم تنجح موسكو و
وواشنطن والامم المتحده في اقناع جميع
الاطراف لاحترام ال الجدول الزمني الذي
اقترحه في نهايه ايار او قبل نهايه شهر
حزيران الان الموضوع تاجل على الاقل لشهر
ان لم يكن لاكثر ولكن التاجيل في اطار مثل
هذه التغييرات على ارض المعركه من الممكن
ان يعرض هذا اللقاء
المقترح الى الخطر يعني من الممكن لاحد
الاطراف خصوصا اذا ما كما قلت اذا ما
استطاع النظام ان يستثمر هذا المكسب
لانجازات اضافيه ان في مناطق اخرى ان كان
في حمص او في شمال البلاد او ان كان الخ
خلافات بالنسبه للسؤال الذي سيركز عليه
خلال الايام القليله القادمه من خسر من هو
الطرف الذي خسر القصير ونلاحظ ربما المزيد
من الخلافات داخل صفوف المعارضه يعني كل
هذه الامور من الممكن ان تعرض هذا اللقاء
الى الخطر اسمح لي في الثوان الاخيره اسال
استاذ محمد عبيد في الاخير اذا حضر ممثل
النظام في مؤتمر جنيف
وقد والنظام ما زال يحافظ على بعض
مكتسباته الميدانيه كما حصل في سير ماذا
سيطرح على طاوله المفاوضات ما هو المبدا
الذي سيحافظ عليه
باختصار يعني اولا س يؤكد ان لابد من
عمليه سياسيه سلميه وفق اسس ديمقراطيه
يتفق عليها منذ البدايه كان القياده
السوريه بشخص الرئيس الدكتور بشار الاسد
منفتحا على التغييرات الجذريه في الدستور
السوري وقد قام ببعض الاجراءات في هذا
المعنى انما لم ت تستجب المعارضه ودخلت
مساله السلاح على موضوع المواجه شكرا شكرا
لك محمد عبيد للاسف الوقت انتهى محمد عبيد
السياسي اللبناني من بيروت شكرا لك ونشكر
ايضا في واشنطن الدكتور خالد جشان استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه بيبر داين وهنا
في الاستديو الشيخ رامي دالتي عضو القياده
العسكريه العليا للجيش السوري الحر للاسف
لم يكون هناك الوقت متاح لترد شكرا لكم
مشاهدنا الكرام لمتابعتكم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
وبركاته
ا